antonio sensatella on the mound tonight
for the colorado rockies 26 year old
right hander making his 20th start his
12th at coors field
he's posted a 4-4-1 era six walks only
28 strikeouts across his last six starts
four of them have been quality
left-handed hitting adam frazier the
second baseman will swing at the first
pitch hit a four-hopper to story near
second the rocky's shortstop throws him
out and antonio senzatella in just four
pitches is grabbed two quick outs and
machado good numbers against the rockies
in his career but not this at bat hits
it back to senzadela he runs over and
flips it to cj crone
a seven pitch one two three top of the
first for antonio senza della on the
bound tonight for the padres is ryan
weathers well the last three have been
kind of a rough go around for the young
left-hander 21 years old making his 16th
start over his last three starts 0-3
15-4-3 era overall numbers look like
this 262 opponents batting average in 74
innings
connor the san diego area native and the
university of san diego product hitting
at 285
swinging a drive towards right center
field this has got a chance it is gone
touch him all time for connor joe
gets the first lead off home run of his
career and the rockies take a one to
nothing lead
pitch to blackman here is swung on and
grounded to the right side hosmer way
off the line has it feeds weathers close
play they got him nicely done by both
hosmer and weathers to get the speedy
charlie blackman and three straight
ground ball outs after the lead off
homer by connor
one and one on cronenworth with nola and
hosmer to follow
and he takes this one the other way
towards the gap in left center field
dawes on the backhand tries to get it
back in quickly the throw to second and
he's in safely
jake cronin worth of the double to open
up the second inning that's baseball
coors field style cronenworth to third
with one away and eric hosmer coming up
and another check swing went around and
coming from third is going to be
cronenberg to tie the game so one to one
the score as hosmer is going to reach at
first base on the strikeout what's
likely a wild pitch
hosmer is short lead he does have five
steals pitch this one's bounced to short
story to rogers for one on to first
double play
antonio senzatella will wait to make
sure that the padres don't challenge if
not it's double play number 12 initiated
by the rockies right-hander
and there will be no challenge 2-1 pitch
is dribbled past the mound chasing it
down flipped by frazier out of his glove
is not in time that ball had as funny as
spin as you could imagine as it
corkscrewed
past ryan weathers pitch
loop towards right field tatis will have
to play it on the bounce it's a base hit
for mcmahon
and ryan's first pitch on the way is a
ground ball to second base frazier
flipped to cronenworth did they get the
out there unsure throw to first is in
time and it is a double play
frazier's throw it looked like might
have pulled cronenworth away from the
bag and without the neighborhood play
you never know but the padres get it
done so here's connor joe who has
provided the offense for the rockies
and he's got himself another knock
putting together quite a birthday
so one out single for connor joe
that one's hit up the middle past a
diving cronin worth and into left center
field
base hit for roger stopping at second is
connor joe
couple man on now for trevor story as
the rockies get into the big bats one
two pitch bounced down the third base
line that's fair and rolling down
towards the corner around third scoring
easily is joe on his heels brendan
rodgers he will score standing mr double
trevor story knocks in two and the
rockies regain the lead three to one
trevor story with his team best 29th
double he's down at second for charlie
blackmon still one out in the third
here's the 1-0 pitch to blackman hit
well to center field grisham moving back
at the track it is over and out of here
charlie blackman with his eighth of the
year a two-run shot and the rockies open
up a 5-1 lead going deep on weathers
again
here is a swing and a miss trying to
check could not and strike three so
crone goes down that's the second out of
the inning man coming up with the base
is empty 2-2 on the way and mcmahon
swings and misses strike three good
bounce back for weathers struck out each
of the next two guys after the home run
by blackman damage done though four runs
on four hits here in the third
one out for will myers you bounce into
one of the two dp's the padres have and
this is into left field they sent for
myers with one down here in the fifth
inning third hit of the night for san
diego
chopper towards second rogers to story
to first double play again even with
grisham speed
the rockies turned their third double
play of the night
tesses jr with a multi-home run game
yesterday
out to right center field
[Applause]
one hops the wall and tatis to second
base standing with a double
going the opposite way sensitive as we
mentioned trying to go down and away all
the time this one leaks outer half it's
up a little bit and he stays on it
there's your old for two has grounded
out the short end back to the mound
and frazier will drive a ball to left
center field counter joe on the run did
he get it he did
oh what a catch by connor joe to the
deep part of left center field on a dive
and then hung onto the ball and that big
grin on his face he loves playing the
game and the fans loved him
two down tatis at second base and here
is machado
on the ground and into right center
field to base hit
tatis being waved around he will score
and amanda machado on his second hit of
the night drives in a run makes it five
and two he's played to the eighth carlos
cestevez into the game 43rd game for the
veteran right-hander we talked about
that era collectively for the rockies
well estevez at four six nine
one-two pitch is a high chopper charging
is rogers and can't make the play
i don't know if that ball hit the lip of
the grass it might have on the infield
grass and it just didn't come up it shot
downwards
under roger's glove when they get
machado to the plate who has two singles
and a run batted in but he'll bounce it
to short frazier is forced at second as
story gets it to rogers
no damage with the infield hit good
eighth inning for carlos estebans daniel
bard is 19 saves a career high and 10th
most internationally going into
tonight's game the padres will bring the
tying run to the play with nobody out
here in the ninth inning
[Applause]
huge strikeout by guard through the
slider to strike out hosmer second and
third with two outs trent tonight over
three he has grounded into a double play
and struck out the 2-1 pitch
in the air to left field back goes joe
look it up it's gone
a three-run home run for trent grisham
and this game is tied five to five
trent grisham with a three-run home run
with two outs in the ninth inning is
tied the game cj crone a single on a
walk in three plate appearances right on
right with hudson
and he drives it to right it's got a
chance it is gone the 11th
walk-off win
on the season
you